Щиро вітаємо вас у нашій студії Ми раді
що ви дивитись програму У фокусі Європа
війна в Україні окрім всього іншого
руйнує фіксовані соціальні ролі в країні
особливо ролі жінок захищаючи країну
армія в якій переважають чоловіки не
обходиться аби жінок Усе більше жінок
опановують зброю і вже десятки тисяч
воюють українських військах проти
російського агресора
відбулися зміни зокрема і в інших
професіях
деякі вважались в Україні чоловічою
сферою діяльністю жінкам просто
забороняли працювати у певних професіях
Це добре знає юна залізничниця Вікторія
Кікоть Сьогодні вона справжня новаторка
у своїй роботі і без таких жінок як вона
під час війни просто не обійтися навіть
далеко від фронту
зразу початок роботи є для Вікторії
моментом самоствердження
Вона перша в Україні жінка заступниця
машиніста
дискримінаційні норми до 2018 року
забороняли жінкам виконувати цю роботу
Її вважали ризикованою для їхнього так
званого репродуктивного здоров'я зараз
під час війни це справді небезпечно для
всіх у потягах було важко морально було
важко фізично тому що
їдеш і постійно є якісь тривоги дуже
часто мені випадало бачити як прилітали
ракети ми все-таки Стараємося це все
собі подавляти і продовжувати роботу
тому що від нас залежить не тільки наше
життя від нас залежить життя тих
пасажирів які знаходяться за нашими
спинами
Вікторія багато разів намагалась і
нарешті вона отримала можливість вивчати
умріяну справу
я давала запити багато університетів
багато коледжів навіть в училища давала
запити і питала чи можете ми ви мене
вивчити і всі мені казали лише одне ні
ти дівчина все мені не відмовили тільки
в одному навчальному закладі мені
сказали Так ми тебе вивчимо Ми не маємо
право відмовити тобі в отриманні
професії в отриманні знань Які ти хочеш
Але ми не обіцяємо що ти потім потрапиш
на роботу
проте не задовго до закінчення навчання
стару заборону на виконання жінками
певних видів робіт скасували
Вікторія за кілька місяців до
російського Вторгнення в лютому почала
працювати помічницею машиніста пасажири
наші електропоїзди до станції Гребінка
час відправлення зі станції
київ-волинський 18 година 27 хвилин
роботи багато слід оновити облікові
журнали перевірити швидкість поїзда
сигнали та контактну мережу
поспілкуватися з пасажирами і Якби щось
трапилось із машиністом то їй довелося б
замінити його
Чоловіки спочатку перші місяці два
відносились до мене з такою
насторогою тому що це таке для них це
просто було незвично що дівчина також на
рівні з ними виконує їхню роботу жінки
не вірили що в нашому
суспільстві
патріархальному дівчата можуть займати
певні такі посади
українські жінки стають тепер помітними
скрізь
Ганна Гриценко Наукова експертка з
питань рівності каже що суспільство
змінюється через потреби війни я би
сказала що це взаємний процес Тобто та
жінки які є на передовій Вони
допомагають бути якимось рольовими
моделями для цивільних жінок у
військових професіях та але так само
якби так само жінки які є жінки у
військових професій вони так само хотіли
би мати приклади від жінок із цивільних
професій ви б хотіла якогось прикладу
жінок чоловічих професіях не обов'язково
на війні можна в цивільних Олена теж
хоче бути частиною цього процесу А вона
має диплом з економіки але два роки тому
вирішила піти в армію і зараз служить
на початку війни коли росіяни наступали
на столицю вона служила на Київщині
робити коктейлі Молотова допомагати
людям заказувати ліки навідувати бабусю
у мене почалась таке сумбур з
військового та цивільного Хоча зараз
росіяни далеко від Києва її нинішні
завдання теж вимагають від Олени Великих
зусиль маємо співбесіди з батьками
загиблих ми організовуємо похорони Я
напевно Краще десь була б на блок
постійні вже розмовляли з батьками і
загиблої людини для Олени важливо що в
армії служать також і жінки це необхідно
щоб зламати гендерні стереотипи але вона
також каже що жінкам добровольцям без
військової підготовки часто відмовляють
а чоловіків беруть
Але якщо ти просто так зайдеш зараз він
воєнкомат військомат і скаже що ти хочеш
служити тебе ніхто не візьме якщо в тебе
Ні немає жодного досвіду в тебе просто
не повірять це можливо ще є якесь в нас
такі скептичне ставлення до жінок знову
у потязі вже пізно зміна Вікторії буде
тривати сьогодні мінімум 12 годин
[музика]
потяги стали в цій війні життєво
важливим транспортним засобом і
персоналу завжди не вистачає тут нікого
не хвилює хто головний чоловік чи жінка
взагалі нічого цього не поміняло моє
відношення Таке же саме як і чоловік би
взагалі все одно жінка Головне щоб
справляла свою роботу я так вважаю якщо
жінка сіла за руль потягатого це тут
нічого нема такого
це робота для всіх роботи є ці роботи
Вікторія знає що їй потрібно ще докласти
зусилля аби пройти шлях від заступниці
до машиністки цю ключову роботу все ще
виконує чоловік воно ще повністю не
трансформувалися для цього дійсно
потрібно багато часу потрібно виховувати
молоді покоління З явною думкою про те
що
жінки мають право на
таке саме життя як і чоловіки і мають
такі самі права
Вікторія сподівається що майбутнє
українських жінок покращиться і одного
дня вона стане машиністкою
про ролі жінок ми розповімо вам також в
нашому наступному репортажі точніше про
музиканток у Туреччині вони частіше ніж
їхні колеги чоловіки страждають від
досить самовільного скасування своїх
концертів це стосується артисток який
відкрито критикують різні речі або ж
їхні виступи є чисто провокаційними
тобто все через те чим дедалі більше
незадоволені передусім ісламіські коло в
Туреччині і тому такі концерти як у
мегаполісі адана раптово стають для
музикантів випробуванням на
стресостійкість
[музика]
остання перевірка звуку
турецька співачка акая готується зі
своїм гуртом до виступу
Але чи відбудеться насправді концерт у
південному турецькому місті адана
[музика]
останніми місяцями багато виступів АК і
скасували часто безпосередньо перед
початком
про те що наш концерт у мерсіні
скасували Я прочитала Напередодні у
Твіттері
щоразу це завжди досить важко адже зали
вже орендовані апаратура в дорозі
музиканти заброньовані і тут раптом
через те чи інше розпорядження концерт
заборонено
ніколи раніше у Туреччині не було
заборонено стільки концертів і
фестивалів як цього року
список одних тільки скасованих музичних
фестивалів довгий деякі з них щороку
відвідують десятки тисяч людей
заборони зазвичай обґрунтовують охороною
громадського порядку але вилкай акай є
інша підозра
Вони намагаються нав'язати нам Певний
спосіб життя
часто від заборон страждають співачки
оскільки ці люди вважають що жінки
повинні сидіти вдома
або це стосується музикантів які
відстоюють більше справедливості та
свободи
це сприймається як критика уряду і так
їх примушують замовкнути
популярна поп співачка гюльсен коли очі
правлячим релігійним консерватором під
керівництвом президента держави ердогана
і з іншої причини
на думку про владних ЗМІ її убогий одяг
порушує цінності народу зараз вона
повинна відповісти Перед судом за нібито
зневажливі висловлювання щодо ісламських
релігійних шкіл
після міська партія хода-пар підтримує
репресії уряду для них це питання моралі
всі концерти спонукають людей звикати до
такої моральності
економічну кризу існує ще й криза моралі
та порядності
моя моральна криза лише посилюється
такими концертами які несумісні з нашою
Вірою
рок і поп-музика як вилка акая для
консерваторів у Туреччині така ж
небезпечна як наркотики
однак для глядачів адані це лише
відмовка вони побоюються що Туреччина
стає все більш релігійною
заборонено вони хочуть запобігти
подальшому розширенню цієї частини
суспільства та його культури
за своє життя Ми відвідали незліченну
кількість концертів і насолоджувалися
ними а Звичайно ми стурбовані тим що для
наших дітей це стане недоступним
[музика]
все ж відбувається публіка у захваті від
такої критичної співачки у своїх піснях
вона постійно співає про свободу
Це був яскравий музичний вечір
[музика]
[оплески]
однак у Туреччині стало тихо рок і
поп-музика виставляється як моральна і
критики підозрюють що все це для того
щоб задовольнити консервативних виборців
перед волевиявленням наступного року
після міській партії такі як худа-пар
бачить сприятливий момент
варто постійно говорити не про ці
заборони А про альтернативи для молоді
Ми також організовуємо концерти
спортивні та культурні заходи але вони
направляють молодь на наші цінності та
традиції
[оплески]
турецькими провінцями закінчується
сьогодні ввечері
[оплески]
наступний концерт також скасували
цього разу організатори можливо під
тиском влади
засоби до існування забирають не лише у
мене а й у десяти моїх музикантів і
співробітників та їхніх сімей ця
політика водночас не законна і
несправедлива
проте гілка якая та її численні турецькі
колеги музиканти продовжують виступати
проти загрозливою тиші в країні
Середземне море уздовж італійського
узбережжя прекрасний клаптик Європи але
життя під водою часто під загрозою через
надмірний вилов риби вперед прибережним
містом та ламоне у Тоскані ця чутлива
екосистема тільки відновлюється і цей
чоловік відіграє в цьому вирішальну роль
рибалка Пауло фаншулі він бореться за
незайманий підводний світ за те щоб
ловити стільки риби скільки може віддати
море і оскільки його бачення поділяють
на всі рибалки Пауло фан Джулі дещо
вигадав
[музика]
довгий день закінчується для паулофан
шулі лише вночі
його траулер повертається у Гавань
таламоне але Пауло не тільки рибалка він
також бореться з незаконними методами
рибальства особливо з донними тралами
через що має багато ворогів
[музика]
мене ненавидять рибалки браконьєри мене
залякували погрожували вбити проганяли з
усіх рибних ринків І що найгірше влади
замість того щоб захистити погрожувала
мені
вони буквально є каменем спотикання
мармурові скульптури на дні моря
затоплені Пауло
вони повинні зберегти популяцію риб і
корали бо дорогі трали рибалок
браконьєрів застрягають на об'єктах
мистецтва і рвуться
рибалки браконьєри мене ненавидять
крупні риболови не хотіли щоб я
затоплював у морі ці великі мармурові
брили ці витвори мистецтва тому що через
них вони більше не можуть рибалити але
вони зобов'язані ловити рибу на відстані
5 км від берега а блоки знаходяться на
відстані 500 метрів від берега
Пауло працює у морі з 15 років Він
бачить як розростається Промислова
рибальство на його батьківщині але рибні
запаси лише зменшуються і з часом здобич
у його сітях залишалося все менше для
таких маленьких рибалок як пауловили
вони забаром більше не вистачатиме для
виживання
у традиційному рибальстві сітка
залишається на з морським дном не
руйнуючи екосистему
при Промисловій ловлі риби трали
опускають на дно і потім тягнуть їх
ланцюгами вагою кількатон так усе
знищується це так само якби мисливці
спалювали ліс щоб убити дикого кабана
[музика]
щоб захистити море не відмовляючись від
своєї пристрасті він винайшов риболовний
туризм
відтоді він бере туристів на свій катер
і пояснює їм всю ситуацію
щоразу Він розповідає про своїх ворогів
рибалки браконьєри не зупиняються навіть
перед морськими заповідниками
[музика]
і про те як власник кар'єру подарував
йому колись сто мармурових блоків
[музика]
так як митці з усього світу
вирізьблювали з них скульптури вагою
кілька тонн
[музика]
як він подолав бюрократичні перешкоди і
як потім статуї вивезли у море на
понтонному кораблі та встановили на дні
[музика]
момент народження каса день печі будинку
риби це парк підводних скульптур у цьому
парку запаси риби вже відновились адже
риба знову знаходить безпечні місця
нересту
мета нашої роботи захистити море та
відновити те що зруйнували людину
але на думку Павло зробити внесок можуть
також і споживачі
я завжди кажу ми рятуємо навколишнє
середовище за столом
бо якщо ми продовжуватимемо споживати
рибу яка була виловлена промисловим
способом або була вирощена на гормонах
то ці рибалки браконьєри ніколи не
змінять свого способу вилову вони будуть
і далі продовжувати виробляти і ловити
рибу більше нестійкій системі
і стратегія Пауло має ще один побічний
ефект
сюди знову повернулася дельфіни оскільки
вони знайшли тут багато риби Вони знають
що вздовж цього узбережжі для них є їжа
Але така тривала боротьба з хижацьким
промислом залишає також і свій відбиток
Я часто почуваюся засмученим і
розчарованим але коли на мій Корабель
приходять гості Це додає мені сил щоб
сказати собі Ти маєш продовжувати
[музика]
тож Пауло щоранку вирушає в дорогу що
врятувати своє море
[музика]
на півдні Франції у Марселі багато
мешканців переживають страх страх перед
кривавими угрупованнями Та
наркозлочинністю яка вже багато років
панує у деяких районах портового міста
ті хто може собі це дозволити
самоізолюється живуть у будинках які
ховаються за ось такими товстими стінами
однак це створює нову проблему для все
більшої кількості мешканців кожен день
починається з подолання перешкод навколо
все нових барикад а це є важким
випробуванням для єдності
А зараз у Великій Британії Усе більше
домашніх тварин виставляють за двері або
неймовірніше просто викидають у розпал
коронавірусу тенденція заводити собі
собаку або кішку була розповсюдженою не
лише у Великій Британії але економічна
криза та стрімке зростання цін зараз
боляче Б'ють по кишені багато британців
просто не можуть собі дозволити
чотирилапих друзів і створюють великі
проблеми притулкам для тварин на острові
що ж викликів у Європі зараз не бракує
ми ж прощаємося з вами Дякуємо за
цікавість і за перегляд до зустрічі
наступного тижня усього вам найкращого
від мене і всієї редакції програми
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив переклад Володимира та Олеся
Швед режисер Павло Тимченко текст читали
Олена потоцька Юрій Лисенко та Олесь
гоян Київ 2022 рік